ever since computers are invented we've
been trying to make them smarter and
more powerful from the abacus to room
size machines to desktops to computers
in our pockets and are now designing
artificial intelligence to automate
tasks that would require human
intelligence if you look at the history
of computing we've always treated
computers as external devices that
compute and act on our behalf what I
want to do is I want to weave computing
may I and Internet as part of us as part
of human cognition freeing us to
interact with the world around us
integrate human and machine intelligence
right inside our own bodies to augment
us instead of diminishing us or
replacing us could we combine what
people do best such as creative and
intuitive thinking with what computers
do best such as processing information
and perfectly memorizing stuff could
this whole be better than the sum of its
parts we have a device that could make
that possible it's called alter ego and
it's a variable device that gives you
the experience of a conversational AI
that lives inside your head that you
could talk to in likeness to talk into
yourself internally we have a new
prototype that we showing here for the
first time at Ted and here's how it
works
normally when we speak the brain sends
neural signals through the nerves to
your internal speed systems to activate
them and your vocal cords to produce
speech on the most complex cognitive and
motor tasks that we do as human beings
now imagine talking to yourself without
vocalizing without moving your mouth
without moving your jaw but by simply
articulating those words internally
thereby very subtly engaging your
internal speech systems such as your
tongue and back of the palate when that
happens the brain sends extremely weak
signals to these internal space systems
alter ego has sensors embedded in a thin
plastic flexible
and a transparent device that sits on
your neck just like a sticker
these sensors pick up on these internal
signals source deep within the mouth
cavity right from the surface of the
skin an AI program running in the
background then tries to figure out what
the user is trying to say it then feeds
back and answer to the user by means of
bone conduction audio conducted through
the skull into the users in a year that
the user hears overlaid on top of the
user's natural hearing of the
environment without blocking it the
combination of all these parts the input
the output and the AI gives a net
subjective experience of an interface
inside your head that you can in that
you could talk to in likeness to talk
into yourself just to be very clear the
device does not record or read your
thoughts it records deliberate
information that you want to communicate
through deliberate engagement of your
internal speed systems people don't want
to be read they want to write which is
why we designed the system to
deliberately record from the peripheral
nervous system
which is why the control in all
situations resides with the user I'm
going to stop here for a second and show
you a live demo when I'm going to do is
I'm going to ask Eric a question and
he's going to search for that
information without vocalizing without
typing without moving his fingers
without moving his mouth
simply by internally asking that
question the a I would then figure out
the answer and feed it back to Eric
through audio through the device while
you see a laptop in front of him he's
not using it everything lives on the
device all he needs is that sticker
device to interface with the AI and the
Internet so Eric what's the weather in
Vancouver like right now
what you see on the screen is the words
are the words that Eric is speaking to
himself right now this is happening in
real time it's 50 degrees in rainy here
in Vancouver what happened is that the
AI sent the answer through audio through
the device back to Eric
what could the implications are
something like this V imagine perfectly
memorizing things where you perfectly
record information that you silently
speak and then hear them later when you
want to internally searching for
information crunching numbers at speeds
computers - silently texting other
people suddenly becoming multilingual so
that you internally speak in one
language and here's a translation in
your head in another the potential could
be far-reaching there are millions of
people around the world who struggle
with using natural speech people with
conditions such as ALS or Lou Gehrig's
disease stroke and old cancer amongst
many other conditions for them
communicating is a painstakingly slow
and a tiring process this is Doug Doug
was diagnosed with ALS about 12 years
ago and has since lost ability to speak
today he uses an on-screen keyboard
where he types in individual letters
using his head movements and it takes
several minutes to communicate a single
sentence so we went to Doug and asked
him what would what would the first
words he'd like to use or say using our
system perhaps a greeting like hello how
are you or indicate that he needed help
with something what Doug said that he
wanted to use our system for is to
reboot the old system he had because
that's old system kept on crashing we
never could have predicted that I'm
going to show you a short clip of Doug
using our system for the first time
reboot computer what you just saw there
was Doug communicating or speaking in
real-time for the first time since he
lost the ability to speak there are
millions of people who might be able to
communicate in real-time like Doug with
other people with their friends and with
their families my hope is to be able to
help them express their thoughts and
ideas
I believe computing AI and the internet
would disappear into us as extensions of
our cognition instead of being external
entities or adversaries amplifying human
ingenuity giving us unimaginable
abilities and unlocking our true
potential and perhaps even freeing us to
becoming better at being human thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay I want to ask you a couple of
questions they're gonna clear the stage
I feel like this is amazing its
innovative it's creepy it's terrifying
can you tell us what I think I think
there's some uncomfortable feelings
around this tell us is this reading your
thoughts will it in five years
is there a weaponized version of this
what does it look like so our first
design principle before we started
working on this was to not render ethics
as an afterthought so we wanted to bake
ethics right into the design so we
flipped the design instead of reading
from the brain directly we reading from
the voluntary nervous system that you
deliberately have to engage to
communicate with the device while still
bringing the benefits of a thinking or a
thought device so it brings the best
best of both worlds in a way for you
also you said that it's a sticker so
right now it's it's just right here is
that the final iteration what it's good
what the final design you hope looks
like our goal is for the technology to
disappear completely so if you mean if
you're wearing it I shouldn't be able to
see it
you don't want technology on your face
you want it in the background to augment
you in the background so we have a
sticker version that conforms to the
skin that looks like the skin but we
trying to make an even smaller version
that would sit right here yeah okay
I feel like does anyone have any
questions they want to he'll be here all
week okay thank you so much Arnab thanks
Ron